item number one is the adoption of our
agenda if there are no objections from
your side I propose to adopt the agenda
as it stands
item number two my brief announcements
are meeting dear colleges is usually
being web streamed for this meeting we
have interpretation in the following
languages German English French Italian
Spanish Portuguese Swedish Latvian
Lithuanian polish Slovakian and
Bulgarian
item number three
I would like to very warmly welcome Ian
stoltenberg the Secretary General of
NATO
diyan stoltenberg once again a warm
welcome to the European Parliament to
this joint meeting of our Foreign
Affairs committee and our subcommittee
on security and defense
[Applause]
since you last participated in a similar
format in July last year several
important milestones and developments
took place on the international and
security scene the Russian war of
aggression against Ukraine has as we
have all witnessed provoked a tectonic
shift on the geopolitical landscape and
has brought the fully fledged fallback
to Europe and to our borders this shows
the need for closer cooperation with
NATO and like-minded allies across the
globe
Secretary General we are aware of the
significant results of the recent NATO
Summit in Vilnius on the 11th and 12th
of July one of the key issues is
Ukraine's NATO membership ukrainians are
not only defending themselves their
freedom and their future they are also
defending our values of freedom and our
future
another important step was the
establishment of the NATO Ukraine
Council this joint body replacing the
NATO Ukraine commission will also serve
as a crisis consultation mechanism
between NATO and Ukraine so dear
Secretary General we would like to hear
your views related to all questions
around the Russian war of aggression
against Ukraine another important step
wasn't is Finland and Sweden's access to
Nato from an EU perspective we've only
welcome this important move Secretary
General how do you see the balance of
powers within the alliance and finally a
point regarding EU NATO Corporation I
warmly welcome the signature of the
third joint Declaration on the 10th of
January I would like to hear from you
your analysis regarding implementation
of the 14 points set out in this
political declaration you know
importantly European Defense
capabilities should be compatible and
complementary with NATO our first and
foremost security guarantee
I would now like to give the floor to
the Secretary General but before let me
hand over to our chair of our
subcommittee Natalie luazor for her
introductory remarks please
thank you
David and from foreign affairs I'd also
like to welcome Mr stoltenberg this is
our first exchange since the summit in
Vilnius we briefly Broach this intolered
with the informal meeting of the defense
ministers which I participated in to
represent the parliament you weren't
able to be there so this is a great
opportunity
the summit of course took a place in the
context of the war of aggression against
Ukraine from Russia there were high
expectations for this Summit from
Ukraine they expected clear information
and signs about
joining and aid for defense
and they had priorities such as the
Eastern Front
in terms of the joining of a Ukraine and
the perspective joining of Sweden there
were less
specific uh signs than expected
compared to the Bucharest Summit
there were no real
um security guarantees
the uh
Aid in the G7 context does compensate
somewhat
for this Summit but in terms of Sweden
joining I congratulate you on your
efforts uh
for going around the impasse imposed by
turkey
without compromising a transatlantic
security we impatiently await
the the uh
compromises made by president erdogan
so that Sweden will be able to rely on
its own uh security
could you tell us
where
um things are when it comes to uh
the discussions with erdogan
we consider the cooperation between NATO
and the EU essential for a piece in this
area
and in terms of added value to
um
peace in Europe
we hope that we will be able to put an
end to uh
useless quarrels
I'd like to touch on a few things with
Ukraine any doubt when it comes to
giving military aid to Ukraine will only
increase the human cost of this war
we can't just promise to help Ukraine
for as long as possible although this is
uh desirable
we need to know
concretely what the Allies are ready to
do
to support a counter-offensive
when it comes to training
Ukrainian troops we are
leading an unprecedented effort
what can be done to better coordinate
these training efforts between the EU
and certain NATO allies
this is an example of good uh European
cooperation
these are only a few uh matters that
were discussed in the summit
when it comes to Nato defense plans I'd
like you to talk to us about military
mobilization or Mobility
I'm not sure these efforts have gone far
enough yet so I'd like to hear your
feedback on that topic thank you thank
you very much Natalie lazul for your
introductory remarks and without further
Ado I now give the floor to our
Secretary General of NATO Jen
stoltenberg please
thank you so much Mr chair Madame chair
David Natalie and and
their friends in the European Parliament
is it is really a great pleasure to to
see you again to engage with you again
here in the European Parliament because
I
really appreciate this expression of uh
NATO EU EU cooperation to meet with you
and as you know to strengthen the
cooperation between NATO and the
European Union had has been a top
priority for me uh since I uh started my
tenure as Secretary General of NATO in
2014. I believe in NATO EU cooperation
because we share the same values we
share the same challenges we are two
different organizations but we have a
lot in common as you know 600 million
Europeans live in a NATO country
and when Sweden joins uh NATO 96
of the citizens of the European Union
live in NATO country so yes we are
different different institutions but we
have a lot in common
uh and therefore it is uh good to see
that over the recent years we have been
able to strengthen NATO year cooperation
uh on Cyber on Space uh on critical
infrastructure on Military mobility and
we work hand in hand in the western
Balkans in in Kosovo and also in
addressing the illegal migration uh
India GNC and in many other areas and
this is also reflected through the fact
that as you refer to that
earlier this year I signed the third
joint decoration between
the two EU presidents um uh president
vondolian and president Michelle
and then they participated in the EU
Summit in Vilnius
was there as I participated in June I
met with all the all the EU leaders in
the European Council so so we meet at
different levels we work closer together
reflecting the reality that we have so
much uh together and need to to work
together so I would like to commend you
uh
um uh as European parliamentarians for
supporting these efforts enabling uh the
strengthened cooperation between the
European Union and NATO and and of
course we have a lot uh more to do but
we could be quite proud of how far we
have been able to move over the last
stairs in in in in ensuring the
partnership the bond between our two
organizations
NATO EU cooperation has always been
important but the war in Ukraine has
made it even more important
uh because this is the most brutal um uh
War we have seen uh the biggest uh War
we have seen in in Europe since the
Second World War uh and that makes it
even more important that we stand
together
and the reality is that President Putin
made at least two big strategic mistakes
when he invaded a Ukraine last year
the first and most important was of
course that it totally underestimated
the ukrainians the strength the
commitment the courage of the Ukrainian
people the Ukrainian political
leadership and the Ukrainian Armed
Forces
the other big strategic mistake he made
was to underestimate us
our willingness our our
uh commitment to support Ukraine to
stand by Ukraine with economic sanctions
with political support but not least
with the military support and that's uh
and that's unprecedented what we have
seen now of a military support from NATO
allies from EU members from EU from NATO
uh and and and and and this is a support
which is much bigger than anyone
expected when this war started with um
with Advanced uh artillery with uh with
the long-range cruise missiles uh uh
with uh with uh Advanced Air Defense
systems uh with a lot of uh ammunition
and not least training from EU from NATO
uh allies and and now also I would like
to commend the Netherlands Denmark and
also Norway for announcing that they're
ready to deliver f-16s and many other
eyes
have also announced that they are ready
to start training of Ukrainian pilots
and and technicians to enable them to
have
f-16s so again there is much more we
need to do and we need to support and
sustain this support but if you just
stop for a moment and think where we are
today compared to where we thought we
were going to be just weeks ahead of the
Innovation I think we need to to
recognize the the the the the strength
the commitment not least enabled by the
European Parliament uh for EU members
for innate allies for our institutions
to stand by Ukraine and and and and
that's extremely important to recognize
because this is something that needs to
continue our support has helped to
enable the ukrainians to launch the
counter-offensive
ukrainians are gradually gaining a
ground
um and it is an improves uh the
importance of our support and also our
ability and and willingness to continue
the support because this is heavy
fighting difficult fighting but I have
been able to breach uh the uh defensive
lines of the Russian forces and they are
moving uh moving forward
um as you and that was also the clear
commitment and clear message from the
NATO Summit uh in July uh that we need
to continue to support Ukraine that has
been the message from the European Union
again and again uh and uh and the
offensive just highlights the importance
of of standing by them
um
at the NATO Summit
um the the main message was of course
support Ukraine we were also able to
make progress uh on uh Ukraine's path
towards uh uh NATO membership
um we we recognize what the European
Union has done in granting them candid
status
um in NATO uh at the venue Summit we
made important decisions to help to move
Ukraine closer to a membership we
reiterated that Ukraine will become a
member of NATO
but then we added three elements which
actually moved them closer to membership
first we agreed a substantial package
and also funding for a substantial
package to ensure full interoperability
between the Ukrainian armed forces and
NATO and interoperability between our
Armed Forces is really a way to in
Practical terms move NATO closer and
move Ukraine closer to uh to Nato
membership the second thing we did was
to
strengthen their political
institutionalized cooperation we
established something called the native
Ukraine Council where we don't meet
Ukraine as a partner we meet as equals
around the table uh 31 allies soon 32
and then with Ukraine around the table
as an equal this Council can make
decisions it can conveniently they
showed notice it can address a crisis as
we did just after the summit with uh
when the when the grain deal was
suspended uh and and and the plan is now
to really develop the NATO commission to
a practical to an important tool to
strengthen the bonds between NATO and
and Ukraine and the third thing we did
at the NATO Summit was to remove the
requirement for membership action plan
for Ukraine to become a member because
previously the idea was to Grant the
country membership action plan and that
was a step towards invitation at the
Village Summit we said that there is no
need for membership action plan because
uh Ukraine has already moved closer to
to Nato so we turn now the membership
process
um from a two-step process to a one-step
process and these three things uh the
interoperability the network Ukraine
Council and removal of the requirement
for a membership action plan for Ukraine
are demonstrates that Ukraine has never
been closer to a membership in NATO than
now and let me just end by saying that
this reflects the political reality that
nations are sovereign Nations decide
themselves and Ukraine has of course the
right to the trial to decide his own
path and it's up to Ukraine and they
need to analyze to decide uh when
Ukraine becomes a member Russia cannot
be to a membership for any Sovereign
independent state in in
in Europe the other Main
issue at the NATO Summit was to
strengthen the terms and defense
because fundamentally NATO has two tasks
uh when it comes to the war in Ukraine
one is to support Ukraine as NATO allies
and NATO does do the second is to
prevent escalation
and the uh therefore
we have already increased our presence
in the eastern part of the alliance to
send a very clear message to Moscow to
remove any room for misunderstanding
miscalculation that NATO stare to defend
every inch of NATO territory one for all
all for one uh uh at the NATO Summit we
agreed new plans uh uh for the defense
of the whole Alliance uh we also agreed
to establish and to identify a more High
redness troops 300 000 troops on
different levels of high redness and
also have more air and enable
capabilities
um ready to quickly reinforce if needed
the purpose of this is to prevent War
the purpose of this is to ensure that
NATO continues to be the most successful
Alliance in history because we have
prevented any military attack on any
NATO allies and when there is a
full-fledged war going on in Europe then
becomes even more important that we have
credible deterrence and by strengthening
of the turns on defense we are
preventing World preserving keys for
NATO allies because there is no room for
miscalculation
um and the third thing was that um
NATO allies uh have really now
demonstrated that they are delivering on
the commitment we made in 2014 uh
because the war didn't start in February
last year it started in 2014. the
full-fledged Invasion happened last year
but the war the illegal annexation of
Crimea uh Russia went into istanbulse in
2014. since then NATO has implemented
the biggest uh adaptation of this
Alliance in modern history in in decades
and part of that is to invest more in
defense I think I've told you before
that I know it's hard to allocate money
for the events because
most politicians want to spend money on
Health on education on the
infrastructure instead of Defense but
sometimes you have to invest in defense
and when tensions are going up risks are
increasing that we have to invest more
and this year we expect NATO allies to
increase defense spending by more than
eight percent in real terms this is the
biggest increase in decades and it shows
that uh allies are now and of course
many of them most of them are are also
EU members are now taking this very
seriously more money for defense also
enable us to invest more in production
of ammunition which is extremely
critical I welcome the efforts I welcome
the decisions by the European Union
which goes hand in hand what we do in
nato in NATO have that we have different
uh arrangements for joint procurement of
our mission we have done that for many
years we have something called the NATO
support and procurement agency I welcome
uh efforts by EU members NATO allies to
join the ramp up production and we work
closely with the defense industry
throughout the alliance in in EU but
also in non-eu Allied countries
to produce more and more spending is a
pre uh condition for also uh increased
production
um then lastly
um uh on on Sweden first of all it is
historic that uh now Finland is member
of the alliance
um and we have to remember the
background the background was that
President Putin declared in the Autumn
of 2021 and he actually sent a draft
treat that they wanted NATO to sign to
promise no more NATO enlargement that
was what what he sent us
and that was that that was a pre
condition for not invade uh uh Ukraine
of course we didn't sign that
the opposite happened
he wanted us to sign a promise never to
enlarge NATO he wanted us to remove our
military
infrastructure in in all allies that
have joined NATO since 1997 meaning half
of NATO all the Central and Eastern
Europe we should remove NATO from from
that part of of our Reliance introducing
some kind of e and b or second class
membership
we rejected that so he went to the war
to prevent uh NATO more NATO closest
borders he has he he has got the exact
opposite he has got more NATO presence
in the eastern part of the Lions and he
has also uh uh seen that finan has
already joined the alliance and Sweden
will soon be a full member because at
the winner Summit
we agreed
um
a a statement where it was clearly
expressed how Sweden will do more uh
follow up the agreement we had in Madrid
on fighting terrorism
um and also address issues related to
export of of military equipment and then
turkey and may declare that they will
ratify as soon as possible this has been
reiterated by President several times so
I expect that when the Turkish
Parliament reconvenes later this Autumn
uh the ratification will happen as soon
as possible which has been stated again
and again and then we will be 32 allies
and both Sweden and Finland will be
members uh this is this is good for uh
the Nordic countries it's good for
Finland and Sweden and it's also good
for NATO and it demonstrates that when
President Putin invaded a European
country to prevent more NATO he's
getting the exact opposite I I think I
used my 10 minutes or even more so so I
think I stopped there to allow as much
time as possible for comments and
questions and looking forward to our
discussion so thank you so much
thank you very much Secretary General
stoltenberg for your introductory
remarks that was good input for our q a
session
I now first skip the floor to our
chairman of the delegation for relations
with NATO parliamentary assembly Tom
fontenada Tom the floor is yours for
three minutes thank you for the floor
David and I also appreciate holding this
very timely important and indeed already
traditional exchange of views with the
NATO Secretary General Mr sultanburg I
want to congratulate you for another
year at NATO's Helm but also pay tribute
to your leadership dedication and your
commitment to keep us as Europeans free
and safe and if I look back at the
Vilnius Summit I was glad to see the
sustained demonstration of transatlantic
unity and determination in responding to
Russia's war of aggression against
Ukraine I think in Vilnius The Alliance
came up with the right responses to the
challenging to the challenges we're
facing together
it is clear that NATO remains essential
for the security of our continent the EU
and the partners in Europe and all
citizens involved and that's why I think
we should continue to focus on the
partnership the strong partnership
between the union and NATO allow me
three short questions in that regard the
first one beyond the obvious need to
continue working together in supporting
Ukraine what indeed would you describe
as the most urgent priorities of EU NATO
cooperation after the signature of the
joint declaration the second question
with regards to our legislative ambition
on the joint procurement of military
equipment ederpa and the act in support
of ammunition production ASAP as well as
to NATO's new defense and production
action plan what would be your
assessment of the coordination between
EU and NATO concerning the delivery of
military assistance to Ukraine precisely
the coordination between the um the two
and thirdly and lastly and I've already
asked this question to you before
regards regarding the protection of
democracy how would you assess the
feasibility of effectively establishing
the envisaged NATO Center for Democratic
resilience still under your term in
office it's an institution in which
congressman Gerald Connolly and I have
been pleading for already in the past
thank you so much for being here with us
today and for the Frank Exchange thank
you Tom and now I hand over to Natalie
Lazo she will chair the second part of
our meeting
thank you David
David and City coordinators for two
minutes each uh and the first is Mikhail
Gala for EVP of it
thank you very much Secretary General
for your input here and your continuous
presence in our in our committees I
think that's very valuable for us and
that would also particularly also as the
standing rapporteur for Ukraine thank
you for your continuous and Relentless
uh efforts and and policies to to
strengthen uh Ukraine's defense
capabilities and to to motivate Our
member states to deliver
constantly and and more as as definitely
more is needed
um and I wonder as you referred it was
referred to our ongoing legislation
ederpa and azab when it comes to to uh
better standardization and and also the
efforts to get the uh common procurement
better do you see potential in our
legislative part that we can deliver
better for the common cause uh do you
see there concrete points where we
should embark on in in in the in the
immediate future one question another
totally different one when it comes to
the grain Corridor uh what Ukraine has
unilaterally declared uh as the Black
Sea is not an exclusive Russian domestic
sea but an international waters how do
you see how could we uh help Ukraine
secure this let's say for the area as
soon as we enter uh either Romanian
Waters or the international waters that
they could be well you know further
south is of course
I thought you were you're involved
included there but my point is to say
that we in international waters and
Romanian and Bulgarian Waters we can
definitely be present is there a plan to
secure such a grain uh in in the future
and last appeal behind the scenes please
push on all hesitating governments and
in my German case please push behind the
scenes the German Chancellor in person
to deliver the Taurus missiles that is
my concrete plea to you thank you
thank you uh now we go to tonino pitsula
for uh snds
Mercy welcome to fset credit General
it's good to see you here since the
timing of exchange is very very relevant
unfortunately I would say uh thank you
for your introductory remarks
furthermore I would like like to ask you
uh more of information on following uh
questions as my colleagues mentioned
already European Union is fully
embarking on a mission to strengthen its
own defense industry and encourage joint
production and procurement of Defense
products notably with the recent edirpan
ASAP regulations
how and does NATO plan on engaging in
similar projects and if so will it
coordinate with the EU to ensure
interoperability and smarter more
efficient spending
um
another aspect I'm curious what are the
immediate challenges NATO is facing in
Black Sea in the context of Russia's war
against Ukraine and something I think
it's also interesting to hear from you
can you provide us more information
about Alliance cooperation with Asian
Partners first of all Japan and South
Korea in light of more and more
assertive China's policy in the region
as well pyongyang's ongoing deals with
the Kremlin thank you
thank you for renew your Opera House our
services
thank you Natalie and um
Secretary General most welcome to the
European Parliament once again it's
always a pleasure to have an open and
Frank exchange with you
indeed we're facing absolutely new
security situation whatsoever
and with the Russian missiles at least
parts of them falling on the NATO
territory it's something but we have to
reflect uh appropriately I mean this is
nothing about Theory it's a very gloomy
practice we have to reflect by our
decisions my first question Secretary
General is about the lessons from the
Russian aggression against Ukraine or
lessons from the Ukrainian front uh what
the member states of NATO and those
interlinked with EU must learn so we see
absolutely different level of using
drones I would say the war went
dronized and it's not a limit I mean
which is reached are we learning we are
we taking into consideration uh
absolutely different situation in this
case I mean at least small flying
objects which change as well as mining
uh the density of mining mines used I
mean different mines used in in a war
it's something which hasn't been
predicted by many experts so that's why
the ukrainians are completely right once
they say that we I mean they they fight
something like in between of World War
One and world war three so we have to
probably understand this and my second
Point Secretary General is about the
hybrid threats which come from so-called
private military formations they are not
private I mean they are mostly State
supported but sometimes I mean from my
point of view we simply uh deny I mean
and do not take into full consideration
the existence what can be done and what
kind of the actions we might predict
thank you
um for uh snd again the city
coordinators fan mixer
thank you thank you very much Secretary
General for being with us
[Music]
a question to you regarding or could you
expand on on on two points in the uh uh
final communique of the villains Summit
that you briefly also mentioned in your
introduction uh first the defense
spending pledge which was originally
made in 2014 we've seen significant
progress uh with regard to increasing
defense spending but there's still a
very long way to go so how do you see
the current state of implementation and
what are your expectations of getting
where we want to get and the same
question about the
um
new sort of high availability of the of
the or the of the new pool of high
Readiness forces I mean NRF has been
there for quite some time now we have a
different uh structure that we that we
have set up by by Madrid Summit
communique and and willingness Summit
communique how do you see the the
progress in in the implementation what
do you expect to happen by the end of
this year and Beyond uh when it comes to
the getting to these three hundred
thousand uh
pool of hyrus forces
thank you for ACR vitolver
uh thank you Natalie I'm here a
Secretary General
first of all
congratulations for the
extension of your Monday
we are happy and appreciative
service and performance as a NATO chief
I would like to express couple critical
remarks about The Summit but please
don't take it personally
genius was a good Summit but not as good
as Warsaw Sami for the Easter flag
and is the front security is not
enhanced
by the additional presence of NATO
troops
we were expecting that
and NATO Battalion groups are
turned into brigades or even higher
nothing happened
secondly we've got additional more
detail
elaborating conditions content
plans
but who is going to manage this plant
who is going to command
defense of the Eastern Front there is no
original
NATO command to defend Eastern France so
what are the
benefits for Eastern Frank which is
250 kilometers away from Russian border
and more than
500 kilometers away
from the first
located somewhere in the western part of
Europe to defend Eastern France thank
you
thank you for the left mcwallis
thanks very much Natalie Mr salterburg
NATO has been vocal and identifying
China as a threat
the villainous sum of Declaration states
that China is trying to subvert the
so-called rules-based International
order
and criticizes China for being opaque
about its strategy and intentions
now my first question is how is it
possible to subvert an order that has no
Constitution no basis whatsoever in
international law
if you think it does in fight appeal to
or have a standing in international law
why then do NATO and NATO members
repeatedly violate international law
without any consequence Yugoslavia Iraq
Afghanistan Syria Libya for example
China has not illegally invaded and
bombed a sovereign country in over 40
years
while the U.S and our allies have hardly
stopped in the same period
killing millions of civilians displacing
Millions more and illegally sanctioning
dozens of countries to the point where
tens of thousands of men women and
children arrested judicially executed
each year for simply existing in a
country targeted by Western imperialism
is it not time to return to multilateral
International forums based on diplomacy
and international law like China has
repeatedly urged the U.S to do
in July NATO called on China to play a
constructive role as a permanent member
of the United Nations security Council
and to abstain from supporting the war
effort in any way
the reality is that their positioning
has allowed them to play a constructive
role as a potential mediator for peace
it was NATO de EU and the U.S who
dismissed their peace plan
you yourself ridiculed the plan saying
that China didn't have much credibility
credibility is about consistency and
being believable
China has stayed neutral in the war did
not impose sanctions still trades with
Russia and Ukraine and has flatly stated
that they would not supply weapons to
either side in the conflict
the EU has armed one side in the
conflict imposed massive sanctions but
continues to be one of Russia's biggest
trade Partners tell me Mrs dottenberg
who has the most credibility
now I give the floor to
um Antonio Lopez history white who is
asset reporter on NATO for two minutes
um thank you Mr Secretary General
um I wanted to tell you of course you
only had 10 minutes for your
presentation and uh let me tell you that
I fully share your priorities that were
shown during these 10 minutes but
there's one thing
sorry to say I'm a little bit obsessed
and many some of our colleagues here
also which is our Southern flank
um I might want to hear from you maybe
in the answers a little bit uh more
about this strategy there are very
warning signs coming with uh eight good
attacks in three years in Africa we have
been kicked out of many countries let's
put it in a diplomatic way
so what's what's your point of view the
top priority you know we should be
addressing in this question second I
come from Spain as you very well know
pays only 1.26 of our budget to Nato do
you think this is a good figure could we
improve it we should we improve it
uh I think that's also important to know
from your perspective and third we have
received during this week's informations
that uh q1 Army is now present uh in
Russia ready to take uh action against
Ukraine do you have any intelligence or
information about it uh q1 and the human
Army is not to be you know it's not very
effective but in Cuban intelligence it
is so it is for us a matter of worrisome
that uh they are present or we would
like to know if you have any kind of
thought or information about it thank
you very much
thank you now we have many colleagues
who want to have the floor uh so in
order to have all of you speaking and
more importantly even to have the
Secretary General able to answer I would
really ask you to uh limit your
intervention to one and a half minute
starting with zeliana zofko
thank you
um
sector General
I will ask you the questions that may be
a bit forgotten there's a book called
The my War has gone by I miss him so by
one's famous journalist who was the war
reporter in Boston Herzegovina what
should we do about Boston Herzegovina
um you said that you are jumping over
this membership requirement and so for
so many years NATO was asking so many
questions and pausing and we have so
many uh crisis situation there and
recently Baker zabegovic called all the
Muslim world to unite and help against
the U.S and the Western allies in this
electoral period so is there any chance
that we are having attention there and
doing some preventive diplomacy before
uh this this area becomes again hot spot
thank you
thank you and thank you for being
circumcised now I give the floor to
Elena Young
thank you Mr Stalter Bank in advance for
your answer my question is specifically
about the Black Sea and the Black Sea
countries the Black Sea is about to
become a conflict Zone in which Bulgaria
in Romania to NATO countries can be
directly involved in the war
uh how uh would you comment on such
situation on such a development also do
is expect a revision of the Montreal
treat treaty and how to intend to
implement the possible increased NATO
novel presence in the Black Sea if the
war will escalate so in brief what is
your strategy for the Black Sea can we
expect the full scale scale war in the
blitz Black Sea region thank you in
advance
thank you next is Katarina from renew
thank you Secretary General and thank
you very much for this friend
conversation uh that is possible to
conduct with you here uh and first of
all we would very much uh looking
forward to welcoming Sweden uh in
Alliance because for which my party in
Hungary has been calling for repeatedly
but I would like to ask you two brief
questions
uh first of all as you know here in the
European Parliament uh the Foreign
Affairs and the human rights committees
are working very hard to assist Ukraine
in uncovering documenting against
sanctioning crimes against humanity that
is committed by the Russian aggressor
against Ukrainian civilizations of the
miners and of course our goal is to help
bring Justice to the perpetrators of
these heinous crimes uh so if you could
elaborate a little bit on the most
severe types of crimes committed against
these civilians I think that would be
very much appreciated and also how
effective do you think ukrainians are
importing those crimes and how could the
euro-atlantic community help improve
these capabilities and another question
and I think a lot of us are being
worried about is the situation around
these apresia nuclear power plant that
is currently running on very limited
capacity and based on the export data
provided by the atomic energy agency and
intelligence how would you assess the
current level of threat and if the front
lines move in the area of the nepro
river how do you think the ukrainians
can and take it back safely do
contingency plans exist for the
different scenarios in this very
dangerous environment and also for
divide our central eastern European
region thank you very much
thank you next is her Martin for ECR
thank you thank you very much Mr
stalkenberg it was very interesting aux
position I have to require two short
questions and one of them
is about turkey and we have a in Turkey
a NATO member who was a very special
special role in this crisis
and Summers of us Wonder a way it is in
every moment with this
special connection which it does
indeed with with Moscow and the Special
Operations they they
um they handle between erdogan and Putin
which are more or less outside they they
come in front of the of the NATO policy
and the other one is the connection
which was referred by my colleague is
Juliet with with Cuba we know now we
confirmed that we have we have soldiers
on the front in Ukrainian
on the spot a Cuban soldiers a we wonder
how long it will take that we have other
people of the forest Sao Paulo like
Venezuela and Sony Caravans in this in
this part of the world as we have
Russians as we have Russians in there in
their countries so a isn't it necessary
that the NATO takes really and and
overall a look on what we are doing with
some Latin American countries as Cuba
which we are supporting after knowing
this kind of actions thank you very much
thank you
can you please switch off your
microphone sure thank you
next is Claire daily
thanks president
um Mr stoltenberg you asked us to look
at where we are today compared to When
The Invasion started I'm not really sure
what you meant by we I know you spent a
lot of time on nasal maybe that's the
way about the expansion with Sweden and
Finland but you were considerably
quieter about the bitter disappointment
experienced by Ukraine in buildings that
the hopes that they taught of apart into
NATO didn't actually work out according
to plan their chair said that age
somehow compensated which others have
kind of said is that solenski's silence
was basically purchased but in essence
really haven't you let Ukraine down in
terms of the pathway to membership and
on the subject of Ukraine is it not the
case that your rhetoric and reality are
going in opposite directions and the
world is beginning to notice because you
said that Ukraine is gradually gaining
ground that's not true since you were
here the last time Ukraine has lost
territory
a half a million men are dead Ukraine
has had to resort to conscription
there's reports of signing people up
with disability with mental illness men
paying money to get out of the country
hiding in their houses we're now in a
Bloody War of Attrition and it's simply
cruel for it to go on now senior U.S
military personnel are even getting into
the pages of the Washington Post and so
on echoing the call made by General
Millie last November that there should
be peace and a real peace if you care
about Ukraine what's your attitude for a
peace plan to save Ukrainian lives
thank you next is Fabio castaldo
thank you thank you very much mothers
Madam president your Secretary General
thank you to be with us today this
morning both to you and NATO as you
underline have recently released
significant documents such as also the
Strategic compass in our case that which
may have been partly overtaken by the
events due to the Russian aggression in
Ukraine but remains ugly relevant and
the NATO strategic strategic concept
historically you and NATO have so to
operate with great coordination and in a
complementary perspective my first
question is about the new opportunities
and synergies that do you see to of
possible further improvements uh in this
partnership I'm thinking in particularly
of the NATO about the NATO Innovation
fund and the Diana program and we should
unw synergize with the efforts that the
U is making to strengthen its defense
industrial base and the develop and to
develop strategic and technological
autonomy primarily through the European
Defense funds among other existing and
Twitter initiatives are there existing
or planned coordination platforms for
these aspects
also I wanted to ask you how can we
ensure that our efforts to achieve great
greater interoperability at the European
level remain aligned with NATO's
interoperability efforts and I would
like also
to ask you if you would support a
stronger and more structured
coordination within NATO among the
countries that are also EU member State
taking into account that now that is
almost a complete overlap and last
question we have news of massive
movements of troops military equipment
and missions from Azerbaijan towards the
border with Armenia that are very
worrisome there is a real risk of a new
Criminal war of aggression by an
authoritarian regime against a democracy
not only in the dispute region of
karabakh but also in in the zanger in
southern Armenia Azerbaijan received
weapons system from several NATO
countries what is your position in the
position on this risk of escalation
thank you
thank you uh next is David Leger
thank you so much chair and thank you
dear Secretary General for taking the
time to be with us here today I just
have to start by saying that as a Swede
I am very grateful for all the hard work
that you have put in to finally make
Sweden a member of the NATO family so
thank you for that
we had a lot of questions today and the
interventions about the southern flank
and the Eastern flank I wanted to to
focus on the other the last flank
because of the recent increasing
tensions between the USA and China and
also its threats against Taiwan so I
would like to ask you what do you think
NATO's role against new transnational
threats like foreign integrated from
China is and also about AI how can AI
play an effective role in this and
actively combat the misuse of AI
thank you
thank you next is dietmakusta
I would like to speak in German
thank you very much
thank you very much Secretary General
for your presentation
we've got a couple of questions the
first relates to
um
bombing and we've had uh huge numbers of
um people killed in Ukraine by cluster
Munitions and we've now heard that
Ukraine is also using cluster Munitions
sent by the US 95 of all people who are
killed or injured are civilians the
European Parliament in May 2009
spoke about the Oslo convention Banning
cluster munition we welcomed it and all
member states
um supported this
so firstly I'd like to say that we spoke
out in favor of this cluster munition
ban so what is the plan here and what is
the plan if Ukraine cannot achieve its
goals
we have seen this war last years already
where millions of people have lost their
lives more and more of Ukraine has been
destroyed and it looks that we're going
to end up in a very very long War a war
that could involve all of Europe and
what should we be doing about that thank
you June next is Javier not foreign
in Espanol
I'll speak Spanish
I want Ukraine to get all that surgery
back including Crimea I want Ukraine to
be part of the European Union and NATO
but reality is somewhat different from
what I would like to see the reality is
if Ukraine is part of NATO we'd have to
be to declare war
to uh against Russia because uh
a NATO country would have been invaded
so until the war has ended Ukraine
cannot become a member of NATO
since 1943 we've seen that even the best
troops of the the SS the panther
were unable to defend 40 kilometers of
defenses from Kursk
even without air superiority it was
clear that Ukraine would not be able to
advance in its much
touted uh
um uh whoa
and going to tamak and Mario Paul
they're they have to go through certain
defenses they've been they've only been
able to make a small dent on Russian
forces so this is a frozen conflict so
what will be NATO's policy
with this Frozen conflict which is a
reality of what we will see in Ukraine
and uh we cannot accept this of course
next is Martin John gyosi
very much Madam chair thank you very
much Mr stoltenberg for being with us
here today and a special thank you for
bringing into your introductory remarks
the reference to the 2021 Autumn Russian
uh
draft agreements that were sent to Nato
and the United States which were not
accepted but which very clearly show the
Russian intentions and Putin's
intentions and I think when we are
talking about this war this is where the
argumentation should start what are the
Russian intentions it is Crystal Clear
what Vladimir Putin's design is and
Ukraine is only the first step in this
strategy and all those people Prime
Ministers who within the alliance are
talking about accepting Vladimir Putin's
peace terms forget this and they should
be reminded of Russia's intentions what
Vladimir Putin sent to Nato and to the
United States is the Revival of the
Brezhnev Doctrine
and all those people who lived for 50
years behind the Iron Curtain should
know what the president of Doctrine is
what Vladimir Putin sent to Nato and the
United States is exactly this so when we
are talking about the war in Ukraine
then we should talk about this draft
agreement and remind all those who
within the alliance are speaking uh
Putin's narrative are wrong and they
should be getting on the side of Ukraine
so my question is Mr stoltenberg is does
the NATO does NATO have the instruments
to fend off these internal uh Trojan
horses and those who want to weaken the
alliance from within by playing Putin's
narrative because NATO when it was
designed after the second world war it
was designed for a classical War like
situation for a cold war but it was not
designed to fend off this type of hybrid
hybrid attacks against the alliance from
within thank you very much
next is our colleague Milan Moon
gracias present I'm going to speak thank
you
I'm going to speak Spanish Mr Secretary
General firstly thank you for your
presence here and your presentation
a great deal has been said about
Russia's war of aggression against
Ukraine I just want to change focus and
uh talk about the Sahel
in 22 and paragraph 22
of uh your communique in Vilnius talked
about uh the the problems in the Sahel
after what we've seen in Niger what is
the situation there
and extending to the bricks with
countries that were what we've seen we
have Saudi Arabia and all of the in this
very strange cocktail Iran all these
countries going to the bricks what do
you think about this Alliance
thank you next is uh Israel
all right
there it is thank you thank you chair
and thank you secretary jail for being
here and let me thank you also that in a
bad moment I sometimes watch the clip of
your previous visit here uh that you
posted yourself after being here because
it encouraged us to stay focused uh and
my first question relates to Ukraine
because we need to give Ukraine what it
needs to win instead of not uh just not
to lose and therefore I want to ask you
we knew we needed to give them the
thanks we started asking for that a year
ago and still we waited we knew we will
need to deliver fighter jets at some
point to secure let the Ukraine secure
their airspace and still we were
hesitating and now we know that they
need these attacks the long-range
missiles can you explain the rationale
behind accepting that Russia can attack
from everywhere Ukrainian hospitals
schools and what have you but that we
are engaging in debates with producers
of these long-range missiles to limit
the range can you explain the rationale
behind that
um to me second question
um relates to what our colleague has
said members
um engaging still with um uh with Russia
um playing lip service to Russian
narratives but also uh non-members that
are exercising with a member a member
state of NATO like Serbia that regularly
almost weekly visits Uh Russian Uh
Russian high-level diplomats or even
visits Russia can you comment on that
and last thing you met with President
vucci did you unequivocally said that
it's absolutely unacceptable to uh
engage or in ignite violence against
NATO Personnel thank you
thank you next is Vlad Georg from renew
Europe
thank you
um very specific questions on a very
specific matter a Russian drone at least
a Russian drone exploded on the
territory of Romania a couple of days
ago a NATO member uh first of all the
Ukrainian side has told us three days
ago at least three days ago that this
happened but the Romanian authorities
didn't find it or didn't admit it until
yesterday uh first question did the
Romanian authorities inform NATO that
indeed there was no
Russian drone explosion did they
afterwards inform NATO that they found
the Russian drone that exploded on NATO
territory and third and very important
what is NATO doing to defend that piece
of border of NATO border because we have
a lot of citizens living there and the
Russians are attacking nearly every
night on that piece of Danube border
near the port of Ismail more exactly so
what is NATO doing for its citizens in
order not to have those Russian drones
exploding more and more on our territory
thank you secretary no
uh Alex colleague Alexander of yondanov
uh thank you I will speak
foreign
Mr stoltenberg
I would like to thank you for
attending yet another meeting of our
committee and for replying to our
questions I have two brief questions my
first question is on
the warning Russia issued about
creating a new security Zone on the
territory of the Black Sea Russia calls
this Zone a new warning Zone this Zone
affects the exclusive economic zone of
the Republic of Bulgaria it is a threat
to the security not only of Bulgaria but
of the whole region
what specific action has been undertaken
to fend off Russian aggression in the
Black Sea more specifically
what is Bulgaria's role within this
specific action my second question is
has already been touched by colleagues
this is the first war in Europe in this
Century where only one party to the
conflict Bears the brunt of it and that
is Ukraine
Russia does not really bear the brunt of
this wall it is not affected by its own
atrocities I would like to know when
finally Russia will feel the brunt of
the war it started when
Ukrainian missiles will be directed at
Russia thank you for your attention
yes next is Nicos apaponrio
yes thank you very much for being here
um you have a very difficult task and
one of the difficult tasks is answering
all these questions which I think show
arrange that any democracy should have
from very pro-war to those of us who
question uh whether this war will have a
conclusion in favor of the Ukraine
that's what we want we hope it happens
fast people are dying and as many
colleagues said it's a very sad
situation we find ourselves here and
from snd supporting a war and supporting
more weapons something that I didn't
expect to do in my lifetime but here I
am supporting the war
uh being Greek I can't tell but hope
that you're you bring your considerable
Prestige and status to ensure that when
Sweden joins it should not become a
bargaining tool for it to reduce its
governance Sweden is one of the highest
levels in the Scandinavian countries
that Greece is jealous of governance
quality of democracy and uh
I hope that the bargaining tool that is
being used by turkey does not
reduce Sweden's Democratic principles
simply because there is a strong
bizarre as they say in Greece going on
and I know you I know you've done much
to get in that direction and I hope you
use your considerable Prestige to ensure
that turkey remains
the NATO member that you we wanted to be
thank you
thank you next and last is Roger
skirtsos for renew
thank you very much and I would like to
thank the Secretary General for his
presentation and for his excellent work
maybe he should not become a central
Banker he should stay in NATO yeah
uh I have a question concerning the
economic performance of Russia it seems
to me that the Russian economy is more
resilient than we anticipated there is a
successful shift towards India in China
and Asia in general they are producing
more weapons with the help of different
countries like for instance Iran they
have a good understanding with Saudi
Arabia and the OPEC plus so they keep
raising try to keep raising the price of
oil and according to what I read to what
I read
their GDP is going to increase from four
to five percent in 2023 this doesn't
mean that they don't have a lot of
problems but it means in my view that
they're in a position to keep financing
this aggressive War for the years to
come
does the secret does Secretary General
share this assessment with me thank you
thank you colleagues a lot of precise
and diverse questions Mr Secretary
General so um I'm sure that thanks to
you will have precise answers the floor
is yours you have 10 minutes
thank you so much I will really try to
address as many as possible of the
issues you have raised but but but there
are so many precise and concrete answers
that the questions that are not not able
to go all into all them but we try to
group them
um and first of all I'd like to thank
you for for uh for the questions for the
interest and also I think that uh this
this session and all the questions you
have asked demonstrates the value of
NATO EU cooperation because most of the
issues you've raised or you should
relate to how NATO and the EU has to
work together to address a common uh
common challenges and many of you ask
questions about Ukraine and how we can
support Ukraine and what we can can do
more for uh for Ukraine and first of all
there is coordination going on
um uh at the political level but also in
the very practical level we have a
coordination cell in this problem uh
where a NATO allies EU members are
together and very practically
coordinating the aid and the support
uh both identifying the needs from
Ukraine and then
approaching different countries ensuring
that we build packages of support
because we need to understand that when
you deliver Military Support it's not
only about delivering a can it's about
delivering that artillery piece but also
the ammunition
the the spare parts the training and
maintenance maintenance facilities so we
can ensure that the whole system can can
work and some of you asked me what is
the top priority and I think in one way
the top priority now is to ensure that
all the systems which are already in
Ukraine actually works
because uh because there is an enormous
need to provide ammunition maintenance
spare parts to ensure that the systems
which are already delivered actually
function I'm not saying that we should
not consider to deliver new systems and
we are now in the process of delivering
f-16s but in the public debate it's
perhaps a bit too much focus on new
systems instead of ensuring that all the
existing systems have all the
maintenance they need to actually uh uh
uh function there is coordination I've
been there myself it's very impressive
how NATO EU allies uh the United States
Canada United Kingdom but also of course
a lot of EU members all together and in
a very practical way uh coordinate and I
ensure we will continue to do so
second on standardization and and
requirement
again I welcome the things that the EU
does NATO has also different programs we
have we met so we realized uh last fall
or last summer that this was going to be
a war of attrition uh so then production
becomes extremely important in the
beginning we depleted our stocks to
provide support Ukraine but our stocks
are not big enough so we need to ramp up
production the reality is that our
production capacity is not as big as it
should be that's the reason why we now
actually see some good progress in new
Investments and more production
throughout the alliance in EU and and on
EU NATO Allied countries
uh I welcome the efforts of the European
Union and NATO as I mentioned how this
uh we have done joint procurement for
many many years through the uh through
the NATO support and procurement agency
and also groups of allies EU non-uh EU
allies are going together and doing
joint procurement and some are just
doing it individually as allies
to be to honest the most important thing
is not the framework where we decide to
run for production and procure
ammunition the most important thing is
that we actually do it be it in the EU
framework or a NATO framework or a group
of uh countries or individual allies and
the thing that really matters is to sign
contracts
we need Nation to sign contracts because
that enables the industry to invest
under ampump production and
standardization is of course key that
has been an issue for NATO for decades
we have now a stepped up uh our efforts
to ensure standardization because we
also seen some gaps there and of course
this has to be a NATO effort because as
you know 80 of NATO's defense spending
comes from non-eu allies so if we and we
need standardization across the alliance
and therefore we welcome the uh the
increased efforts by
by NATO to do more on on standardization
um then uh on the on the offensive and
and where the ukrainians are getting
gaining ground or not
well
I think we have to remember that
no one ever said that this was going to
be easy the offensive it was clearly
stated this is going to be a blood day
difficult and hard offensive
because what we have seen is of course
that the Russians have prepared
defensive lines layers of defensive
lines
with trenches with the obstacles to
battle tanks dragon teeth
and mines enormous amounts of mines
hardly any time in history we have seen
uh more Minds on the battlefield than we
see in Ukraine today
so it was obvious that this was going to
be extremely difficult
but the ukrainians decided to launch
defensive because they are going to
liberate the land
and they are making progress
not perhaps as much as we hoped for but
they are gaining ground gradually
some hundred meters per day
meaning that when the ukrainians are
gaining ground the Russians are losing
ground
and we have to remember the starting
point the starting point is that the
Russian army used to be the second
strongest in the world and now the
Russian army is the second strongest in
Ukraine
and that's quite impressive about
ukrainians
and that's the Courage the will the
commitment the determination of the
Ukrainian soldiers that are making this
possible
and we also need to remember the
starting point and starting point was
that when The Invasion happened the full
scanning elevation happened in in
February we were told by most experts
that
Kiev would fall within days and Ukraine
would fall within weeks
the ukrainians proved them wrong
by pushing back the Russian Invaders
liberating the North
around Kiev the East around hardcave and
then bigger territories in the southern
around Hassan and now they are gaining
more ground liberating more Ukrainian
territory
and then the same experts that told us
that Ukraine will fall within weeks are
complaining about the speed of defensive
the reality is that the ukrainians are
actually
exceeding expectation again and again
and we need to remember what's our
responsibility our responsibility to
support them
we can advise them
but it has to be the Ukrainian
commanders the soldiers on the ground
that make the difficult decisions
we cannot sit here in Brussels in the
NATO headquarters on the Eve
headquarters and tell them exactly how
to fight that's their task their risk in
their lives and we just support them
and we praise them for the courage
and then
and then I say this also because
Wars are per by Nature unpredictable no
one knows exactly where we are in a week
or two or a month or a year from now
and and hardly any War we will see only
once I say victories for the side we
support
there will be bad days and good days
we need to be with Ukraine not only good
times but also bad times
so those who are conveying kind of
message that well only if they win we
will continue to support them no we
support them when they win and if they
lose we are there with Ukraine
because to support Ukraine is not an
option
it's a necessity
to ensure that we preserve peace
for our members for our countries
and to ensure that authoritarian regimes
doesn't achieve what they want by
violating international law and using
military force
so I I just I just
sometimes
it's hard to imagine how brutal this war
is
but but but we need to never forget our
responsibility to provide support to
Ukraine
then I had a concrete question about the
Drone
um uh the possible drone
um the Romanian authorities uh have uh
have confirmed and informed NATO about
that debris from a potential um possible
drone
um have been found near the border uh
with uh Ukraine
um uh they informed NATO allies in the
regular meeting yesterday about all
their findings and the investigation is
going on and it demonstrates the risk of
incidents and accidents we don't have
any information indicating any uh
intentional attack by by Russia and we
are awaiting the the outcome of the uh
ongoing investigation
regardless of that outcome what we have
seen of course is a lot of fighting and
and also air attacks close to Nato
borders and we also had other incidents
in Poland and elsewhere and therefore uh
we have increased our billions we are
closely monitoring what's going on
um uh close to our borders and we have
also increased our presence in the
eastern part of the alliance
um there were questions about the Black
Sea
um
the Black Sea is of great importance for
NATO uh we condemn that Russia has
withdrawn from the Black Sea grain deal
we welcome the efforts by turkey and to
try to re-establish the grain deal uh
and um and uh of course the best way to
ensure safe and secure shipment of grain
from Ukraine is to end the war the
reason why we have these problems is to
go to the war
and then the grain deal is a way to try
to mitigate some of the consequences of
the uh the war let me also say that we
have increased our presence in the
region
um we've done a lot over a long period
of time but especially since uh since
since the war with more Maritime Patrol
aircraft uh with bad groups in Bulgaria
in Romania
um uh and uh and we are closely
monitoring the whole situation in the
Black Sea region including the literal
States
um there were a question about are the
the difference between the villains and
the Warsaw Summit and we told yes also I
will not compare two very successful
Summits uh but but but but there is a
difference is that you're right that in
in Warsaw we decided to deploy new
battle groups
what we did actually
before Wilderness was that we when the
morning of the invasion we activated
NATO defense plans
and by activating NATO defense plans we
give security authority to deploy more
forces where and when he deems that uh
necessary
so he has increased the presence in the
eastern part of the alliance we have
doubled the number of Bugatti groups
from four to eight uh and we have more
air and uh and enabled forces uh
available uh so we we will do what is
needed to defend every inch of Allied
territory this is part about forward
presence but it's also very much about
our ability to reinforce and that's the
reason why a more High redness forces is
the key to address any Potential Threat
caused by the war in Ukraine and
Russia's aggressive actions then I need
to move on as South so many questions
about that the south is of course of
great importance for NATO
um uh the instability in North Africa
Middle East creates
threats and challenges for the whole
Alliance so don't referral for the
southern allies we have our presence in
Iraq to help them train and equip their
forces to uh fight terrorism Isis and we
work with countries like Mauritania
Tunisia to help them fight terrorism
um Stephen Jordan another close partner
of uh of NATO uh but I think we need to
realize that this is also very much
about economic and diplomatic efforts
where also other institutions that NATO
has to play a key roles again an area
where we work together at NATO and the
European Union
um
then China
China we don't regard China as an
adversary but we are concerned about the
challenges that China poses to our
values to our interests and through our
security
China doesn't share our values they
don't believe in freedom of speech
democratic values and they have
expressed that quite clearly
um uh they have they Crackdown on
journalists on on opposition uh on
distance across the country uh we have
seen how they have cracked down on
Democratic rights in Hong Kong we see
how they are threatening Taiwan uh and
uh and uh and we see how China is
investing heavily in a modern nuclear
weapons uh uh more military capabilities
and also long-range missiles and how
they also work more and more closer
together with Russia just before the
invasion of uh of Ukraine Russia and
China signed
an agreement uh where they promised each
other a partnership without any limits
and China has not condemned the invasion
of uh of Ukraine so so so so so I think
what we need to realize is that security
is not Regional security is global uh
what happens in Ukraine matters for Asia
and what happens in Asia matters for us
uh and therefore we welcome the stronger
partnership we have with Asia Pacific
countries uh Australia New Zealand Japan
South Korea participated in the NATO
Summit and and we are ready to do uh
even more to do as much as possible to
work together with these uh these
countries
um then I had then had several questions
about defense spending
well of course how would I like to see
all allies meet the two percent uh
guideline that is not the case
but I'm I'm encouraged by what allies
are doing they are ramping up uh
spending and since 2014 all allies have
increased defense spending back in 2014
when we made the agreement we had only
three allies meeting the two percent
guideline now 11 allies meet the two
percent guideline and almost all of us
have plans in place to be there within a
few years and even those allies are not
at two percent have significantly
increased Germany is one example we're
actually in spending is going
significantly up so yes uh uh uh I I I
see progress and I welcome that progress
then I think since my time is really
running out a few more minutes okay then
I can say one thing about this Paradox
about weapons
uh uh because
um also because
um
because you you said the representative
from uh from uh from uh Greece uh said
that uh that in a way he never believed
that he would support the liberal
weapons to Ukraine and I think for many
people that's a paradox
it is the paradox
because we we all want peace we all want
to invest in something else than uh done
weapons
but the problem is that sometimes you
need to invest in weapons to ensure
peace that's a basic thing
and that has that's that's the lesson
we're learned again and again
and I and I remember very well at the
end of the Cold War we all were able to
reduce defense spending I don't know
exactly defense spending in Greece but I
know that the defense spending in my
country was three percent of GDP at the
end of the Cold War yeah
and then we reduced it to just about one
percent
and I was responsible for that I did not
all of that but part of it because I
wasn't know which politician and across
the lines Paul a government Parliament
reduced defense spending
because tensions went down we saw less
threats we believed in a new partnership
and we believed in the possibility to
work with with Russia and I was a strong
believer in that because we have seen
again in history that that old enemies
can become friends
you see that in Europe France United
Kingdom Germany and France fought each
other for centuries now their closest
friends and allies in the European Union
and if you go to the Nordic countries we
have been fighting each other since a
waking age uh for hundreds of hundreds
of years
and now with swedes and Danes and fins
and Norwegians are you know the best
friends it's a big so it's possible
so I believe it was possible also to
overcome as we're done in Europe for
most European countries within the
framework of the European Union and NATO
it also overcome that relationship with
Russia Russia
didn't choose that path
Russia decided to control the neighbors
to try to re-establish swear influence
and saying that there was a provocation
if a country decided to join NATO it is
not a provocation it is a democratic
Sovereign right of every nation to
choose some path
and therefore we had Georgia in 2008 we
had a Crimea in 2014 and then the full
fledged invasion in 2014. Russia's
walked away and I regret that but then
there is no other option for us than to
ensure peace for NATO allies for EU
members by investing in uh in defense
supporting Ukraine uh because
if uh if President Putin wins in Ukraine
is a tragedy for the ukrainians but it's
also dangerous for us it sends a message
that when they use military force they
get what they want authoritarian leaders
so it's in our security interest to
support Ukraine and therefore I'm
extremely grateful for all the support
that EU members the European Union and
NATO allies are providing to Ukraine
thank you so much
[Applause]
dear Secretary General also on behalf of
Natalie let me thank you for attending
our joint meeting of the Foreign Affairs
committee and our subcommittee on
security and defense we very much
welcome but you take your time to come
to the European Parliament on a regular
basis and your input is very valuable
for our work
colleagues I would like to ask you is
there anything to raise under any other
business
if that's not the case our next meetings
will be on the 20th and the 21st of
September thank you for attending in
your good participation